five home cooks are about to enter a
frantic battle to prove they're looking
credentials that we judged across two
rounds by our own southern comfort chef
Edward Lee pull win and play one
thousand dollars and the title culinary
genius
[Music]
[Music]
this is culinary genius now our five
competitors all think their cooking
skills are the best we are here to put
them to the test they've each brought
their favorite item from their home
kitchen to health and there will be tips
from Gordon Ramsay overseeing the
competition is a world-class chef who is
known for his innovative skills in the
kitchen Edward Lee
all right so five ready excited what are
you expecting from them I'll be testing
you on a very special butchering skill
that requires nimble hands the three
cooks who perform the best get to cook a
meal for me all right in round one many
of today's contestants will be
practicing a culinary skill for the
first time they'll need to learn fast
though because two cooks will face
elimination
so let's reveal today's ingredient
contestants please lift your cloches
it's sausage meat before Edward shows
you today's challenge here is chef
Gordon Ramsay with some tips on how to
make the most of your sausages right
today you get to work with these
incredible sausages now whether they're
pork lamb chicken beef trust me they're
incredible and there's no country in the
world that doesn't have his own take on
the incredible humble sausage what would
I do with these today
Oh pan roast them and then serve them
over a bed of mashed potatoes finished
with the most amazing caramelized onion
gravy right Edward what's the first big
challenge today for our talented cooks
thanks Gordon today I want you to make
six equal sized sausages so we're going
to spread our casing over the lubed tube
now be careful because you don't want it
to tear okay
so load up the sausage maker with the
meat I'm giving you a pork sausage meat
now when you make your sausage what you
don't want is air pockets and air
bubbles so as you're cranking just kind
of push down you see the meat coming out
right there we're gonna go right to the
edge we're going to pinch that off and
we're going to make our first tie at
this point you can crank away
this is the fun part but carefully watch
it you want to make sure that's all
coming out the same width no air bubbles
and the sausages that you make should
you move on to the next round are the
sausages that you will be cooking with
now when we get to the end cut it and
I'm gonna tie off the other end I'm
looking for six even links so just kind
of eyeball it gonna come here make sure
you twist one link towards yourself and
the next one away from yourself okay
look good all right back to your
stations all right then
so our cooks must make six sausages and
place them on to their boards
contestants you have ten minutes but the
battle begins
[Music]
so many options today in our grocery
stores and markets why would it could
want to make their own instead you get
to control what you put in them
obviously you're gonna guarantee
freshness and at the end of the day it's
fun to make hello there David hello
have you made sausages before I eat
sausages quite frequently but I just eat
sausages so I don't cook with sausages
and I know I've never made them
have you done this before no its first
time but I think I got a little method
going on so yeah well you may want to
pick up the pace just a little bit
because I see some of the other
contestants are getting a little ahead
of you
hey look you just cranking away this is
just another day of the kitchen I made
sausages with my parents with my
grandparents I threw out pretty much my
whole life so no wonder you look so
comfortable that's what an Italian home
does absolutely making what is this you
probably an accessory
those are my onion goggles my I'm super
sensitive to chopping onions thank oh
how do I look the pink really see hello
Olli I love this what is this guy that
is a skillet someone like it's seen some
usage over the years as well listen Olli
your sausages are looking a little limp
so get them cranking okay we're over
halfway halfway through your time lesson
Charisse this is a time this afternoon
in the park yes I want to see some some
nice big fat stuff okay
keep at it sir thank you three minutes
just three minutes remaining
[Music]
but David seems to be working pretty
hard over there David's doing well
sausages look good nice firm good size
Daniela is very confident as well as she
should be she's and they've got an
Italian background sausages in her DNA
there's only one minute left so you
gotta get it on the board tie it off
that's the most important thing start
making your links you can't judge it if
it's not on the board
30 seconds 30 seconds make sure than 30
seconds 30 seconds make sure those
sausage links are getting on the board
time up on the board if you have to just
get into the board
[Music]
Hey
[Applause]
[Music]
five contestants have just attempted to
make sausages like a chef but only three
can make it through to the final round
so it is time to find out what Edward
makes of their efforts shall we
all right Sonny so you got six on there
obviously you know they're very uneven
sized this is very long these are very
short they're a little bit skinny
because you needed more meat but you
made like a little baby sausage just
quite impressive I could have done that
if I try they look pretty good actually
you know they're slightly uneven in size
looks like you started small and got
bigger you do have I see of this huge
air pocket but you know you got six on
there pretty good your first three are
perfect and then your last week I got a
little skinny but listen you got all six
in there they're evenly sized they're
just the thicknesses are off the other
thing I would just do is you know cut
that up just to make it look nice you
have six nice sausages again you you you
start it small and you kind of grew and
as you got to the end there this one's
got a little bit of a weird alien shape
to it but the others I mean listen you
got all six on there not bad not bad
you got one guy that tried to get away
you know they're kind of small they've
got some air pockets obviously you had a
little trouble you got these pretty good
and then I think you kind of rushed it a
bit and try to get as much listen kudos
to getting it on the plate
all right well chef now must decide
which three contestants sausages stood
out so we're gonna go take a few moments
[Music]
first contestant going through it to the
final is David
[Applause]
the second contestant to go through is
[Music]
Daniella the third and final contestant
to go through to the cook-off is sunny
[Applause]
you have made it through to the final
unfortunately of course that means that
this is the end of the competition for
Olli and Cherise thank you so much so
for being great contestants here with us
today it's been so much fun to have you
our three remaining cooks have proven
themselves to be worthy finalists now
they'll have to use their sausages and
whatever they can get their hands on
from our pantry to prove their culinary
genius plus they can use their item from
home as well so chef what are you
looking for today
I want a creative delicious dish the
sausages you have are neutral enough you
can go in any direction you want I want
something delicious I want something
that's going to inspire me to crown you
culinary genius contestants it is time
for you to raid our pantry you have just
two minutes your time starts now
chef's what is in that pantry today we
have apples
if kale you can so take there's Thai
basil there's sage just fennel seeds
which would be cool some artichokes
sauerkraut and my favorite beer I don't
normally eat meat and I don't normally
cook crisps hostages so it'll be
interesting 30 seconds 30 seconds in the
pantry closes it's not really sure which
threats and I'm gonna take it in so I
just grabbed really a whole new smash of
things 10 pantry please and return to
your workspace okay now you only have 25
minutes to get cooking and make a dish
that will put a big smile on Edwards
face but the final battle begins
[Music]
hello there Sonny what did you grab from
the pantry some eggs I means tomatoes
making a breakfast dish yes I'm gonna
make like a hash that my dad used to
make us all the time a hash yeah I heard
25 minutes hello there David Oh personal
what did you grab from the pantry today
so what I have is I have the sausage and
then I'm gonna coat them boil them and
then put them in the oven with a sorghum
chili glaze which will add a little
spice to it are you gonna use your chili
powder I may use it on the I'll use it
on the vegetables I believe you've
already got the design onions our first
first thing chopping those onions it's
seriously you tilt your head down you do
know that there's like a big open gap
oil can't sort of jump in and over I
can't live without those goggles they
saved my life
over and over and again so when you're
slicing onions right every time you cut
a knife through the onion it releases
gases and oils into the air and that's
what gets into your eyes you have a very
sharp knife that releases less oils into
the air and also if you do it very fast
you will not cry I guess I need
starburns Ives in my kitchen right
Daniella describe your dish for me
please so it's a warm pie lentil salad
with roasted and sausage and whole-grain
mustard and vinegar dressing 20 minutes
cooks 20 minutes Edward what is your
favorite way to work with sausages so
it's sausages have beautiful fat in them
there's nothing better than grilling
them on a hot grill or getting some char
on them I love serving them on a bed of
lentils yeah with some like sauteed
sauerkraut right over the top maybe a
little mustard sauce cream sauce it's
beautiful that way
so we have Sonny with Sonny wasn't so
excited that she's doing the breakfast
she's doing a sausage and egg hash with
some potatoes me would you just look at
that pantry that we have there's a
million ingredients on there you could
have done anything and she's giving me a
breakfast dish David of doing a sorghum
chili glaze sausage and his little
Tomatoes vinaigrette I mean aside he's
got that great chili pepper I hope these
kind of utilizes that I want something
more than just sausage and sauce both
Sony and gave her boiling your sausages
it's actually you would expect them to
cookies yeah so you don't want to cook
them right on the pan because it's gonna
take too long to cook so you do want to
give them a quick poach let them chill
down really important then use them in
your recipe 15 minutes left 15 minutes
remaining Daniela looks like she's a
skydiver out there are still on there we
go and now we can see her eyes listen
the combination of lentils and mushrooms
beautiful combination classic well these
smells are overpowering but our
finalists have to power on and produce
that perfect dish if they want to be
today's culinary genius three remaining
home cooks are in the midst of a
culinary battle to impress Edward Lee
with their sausage dishes all right
David is this something you're used to
working under this kind of pressure in
the kitchen absolutely not in fact my
whole family doesn't think I'll make the
25 minutes you're the wife and daughter
in the audience yes yeah why don't you
think he's gonna do this in 25 minutes
because he cooks to relax so he goes
into the kitchen on a Sunday and we all
stay out of the kitchen on a Sunday it's
the only quiet time in my house with
four women well they're lucky to have a
chef's dad in you will see if you know
the title today so yeah all right
continue on Thanks
eight minutes eight minutes folks hey
there Sonny I know you're going for your
PhD did this calm you down to cook while
you're cramming for tests and
but under these circumstances not as
much and also $1,000 is a nice chunk of
change to be able to have right as a
student so what would you do with the
money
I've helped with my tuition fee that's
coming up right I bet well keep it up
time is ticking hello Daniela mmm yummy
yummy yummy and I'm noticing this
beautiful engagement ring on your ears
your fiancee here yes so you'll be
having someone to cook for for a while
right hopefully for the forever
hopefully what would you do with a
thousand dollars I'm getting married
so definitely helps for the wedding all
right maybe a honeymoon yeah that would
be lovely wouldn't it it would be all
right enjoy continue on Daniela David
how you doing I'm doing pretty good okay
everything's smoking on your station so
what's that sticky sweet caramelizing
sauce that's the the sorghum a mixture
of molasses and honey yeah so what
happened was all that sauce just went
off your sauce in there onto the pan
right yes so like we got to figure that
out okay sure I'm just nervous right
very very very nervous I've never cooked
for a chef of that quality Sonny how you
doing
you got some raw sausages there okay
don't get me wrong so so just
sausages we're not cooking
I'm hoping that we didn't cook up
minutes Daniela how's it going those
sausages are not taking funny did you
cut one open to see what it looks like
you got everything else done everything
else is ready to go
all right give me a quick summer I'm
worried about Sonny I don't really know
she just chopped up all their sausages
and threw him in a pan
David's burning his sauce in the oven
because he's got a sweet sorghum sauce
so I don't know if that's gonna work
Daniela's sausage just looked a little
bit dry and she's having trouble getting
some carmelization on the outside which
is gonna be a problem because you don't
want wet sausages let's go come on guys
you guys you duckin beautiful beautiful
food
[Music]
see the final part of culinary genius
where Edward is about to judge the
dishes that our finalists have created
let's go right on in I think the
presentation really looks spot-on
I'm just hoping the flavors come through
I'm kind of nervous because I don't
think the chef liked the idea of a
breakfast dish but it didn't kind of
turn out okay I'm known for not cooking
faster so I'm a relief that I was able
to get most of the ingredients on the
plate so presentation-wise it looks
pretty it definitely you nicely recover
didn't give me an ugly breakfast dish
potato pancakes were really nice and
actually that's also is really delicious
it all works together
but it probably just needed one or two
more elements in there if you had
poached an egg maybe and put it right on
top and then had that yolk sort of
spilling onto it that would have been
really delicious you know not the
prettiest presentation you just kind of
got stuff on the plate what's going for
taste isn't that sorghum chili glaze is
marvelous I want more of it it's
probably in the bottom of your pan right
and then when you should have done is
taking some of that sauce and chiseled
it because it was it's really beautiful
the ricotta cheese I it doesn't make
sense here it just kind of doesn't
belong I wish there was more
sorghum sauce on there and I wish the
ricotta head going back to Philly what I
would have done is remember how you put
them in the water so they kind of bled
out I would have just sliced them off so
because it looks where you see how
they're protruding out like that what's
going
pretty good sausage cooked nicely I wish
you two gotten some more caramelization
on the sausage I'm lentils cooked
perfectly the roasted mushrooms are
delicious
it needs a sauce but it's a good dish it
has been a close fought battle but
Edward has chosen the winner
[Music]
finalist please lift your cloches
[Music]
the reason I filtered dish was making
those sausages perfect right from the
get-go they came out beautifully thank
you huge congratulations to Daniela who
is today's culinary genius